ladies and gentlemen good evening I
stand before you tonight to make the
case for the motion and as I do a number
of names and faces flash through my
mind people who are counting on me and
on you tonight to speak for them in this
debate to give them a voice tonight with
your votes Luan Al haul for example a
young women's rights activist who was
jailed in 2014 for trying to drive her
car in Saudi Arabia upon her release
from prison she went to live in the UAE
where last March she was grabbed on the
side of the freeway put in cuffs thrown
on a private jet and taken back to Saudi
Arabia against her will today aged just
29 years old she sits behind bars for
the temerity of asking for women to have
the right to drive Lu Jane according to
her sister as we speak tonight is being
held in solitary confinement where she's
been beaten waterball Ed electrocuted
sexually harassed and threatened with
rape and murder you went on I did go on
um but it's the important point was you
went through this group of people I
think it culminated in Jamal kosi um
which was you were appealing there to
the heart but as you said it's in order
to open the door yeah so I had if you
watched the whole speech it's on YouTube
I had a whole bunch of arguments about
why the West should cut ties with Saudi
Arabia which were about geopolitics
which were about the arms trade which
were about human rights abuses but you
can't open with his Clause four of the
UN Declaration on human rights right
that is the problem with a lot of people
as we say on the left in the labor party
and the Democratic party it's always let
me convince you by giving you one more
statistic one more Fact one more figure
one more peuple one more peer-reviewed
paper that's not how people get
convinced and I say in the book opening
remarks you want to grab people's
attention you want to grab them here not
just here and the best way to to do that
is to tell a story storytelling is the
the number one mechanism for persuasion
for convincing people for connecting
with people so that the audience can
identify with you see something in
common with you bond with especially a
personal story either your own story or
someone around you or the story of
someone they can identify with so I told
a bunch of real life stories for at
least three to four minutes at the top
of that speech one after another before
I got to any kind of facts figures data
or even my actual argument because I
just want to get the audience in the
right mood I want them to understand
what's at stake I want them to feel
something here so given what you just
said there about don't go for one more
Fact one more a surprising tip in your
book is that you say on homework
quantity not
quality no I I say in the context of
brainstorming okay quantity now I say
when you when you're sitting down to
come up with an idea for a speech like
that like how do I come up with a speech
like that I try and give people insights
into how do I construct speeches how do
I construct interviews which I spent a
lot of time on what I say in the book is
that if you go I think it's Alex Osborne
who's the founder of brainstorming back
in the 1950s and he and his proteges
came up with this idea that
brainstorming is about quantity not
quality the idea is to put as many ideas
on the page throw as many things against
the wall see what sticks and if stuff
comes out that's bad no harm no foul put
it in the bin right you it doesn't cost
you anything to come up with a bunch of
crazy ideas so I do the same thing when
I do interview questions I I don't worry
about quality to begin with I put down
on page everything that I could possibly
ask the person in front of me from the
irrelevant to the irreverent and then I
go all right well MSNBC never let me ask
this question oh this one will get me
fired this one's slightly gratuitous
this is a bit unfair this one I can't
back up factually and I get rid of the
ones that and then I refine it down so
when I talk about that in that sense
that's that's more the where do you
start your brainstorming and research
from yeah well look let's see uh a third
example because there's a a whole series
of questions that flow from this it did
uh you know it went viral at the time it
got a lot of attention you were
interviewing um the former National
Security adviser to Donald Trump John
Bolton do you want do we need to queue
in what you were talking about we were
in this I think the clip that they
wanted to play is this is not we talked
about Iraq for a long time but I wanted
to talk about more than Iraq so I
brought up his support for regime change
in Iran and I wondered whether it was
tied to the fact that he was giving paid
speeches to a group of nut cases called
the me this kind of cult anti uh anti-
Muller group that's run by some weirdos
and uh that's was the context for the
questions okay let's see this
clip let me ask you this uh can I ask
how much of your antipathy uh and your
criticism towards Iran I know you've
been very critical of Iran over 15
minutes 15 minutes is nearly up let me
ask you this how how much of your
antipathy towards Iran is to do with
geopolitics how much of it to do with
the fact that you've had a long
association with a group called The me
which was once terrorist group banned by
the state department while you work
there you don't mention it in your book
you I looked in your book there's no
mention of the me I think you took tens
of thousands of dollars for several
speeches just wondering how much that
influences your policy on Iran you know
that I took tens of thousands of dollars
from speeches for speeches at liberal
universities in the United States uh
this is uh this is this is really about
as low as it gets the the fact is that
Hillary Clinton perhaps someone you
support took the M off the US list of
terrorist organizations how about that I
speak what I she she took it off in 2012
you were speaking with them in 2010 when
they were still a banned group yeah now
look that that that you're simply wrong
on your facts on this I see no you were
there in Paris in 2010 speaking at the
MEK rally when there was still a banned
terrorist group according to the state
depart my opinion nobody buys my opinion
and you can ignore that if you want I'm
very comfortable I have never said
anything other than what I believe and
we are now sir 20 minutes into this
interview what you said was for 15 I
believe it's 15 minutes I've got a timer
going off in my ear so we have one last
question before you go and I appreciate
your time fun minutes go ahead very last
[Applause]
question so my question watching that is
why on Earth would any body ever go on
your
show that's a question I get asked by
friends of mine I say don't jinx it as
we Muslims say don't nozer me don't give
me evil eye I need to put food on the
table I need guests to come on my show
but it is a it's a question a lot of
people ask um when I did Eric Prince a
lot of people asked why did Eric Prince
come on your show and I explain who he
Eric Prince is the former CEO of
Blackwater mercenary company it's
probably one of the most viral
interviews I've ever done it actually
got ended up with him getting referred
to the Department of Justice for a
criminal investigation for Alle perjury
because I called him out for
contradictions in his testimony and
people said afterwards Eric Prince this
Republican Trump supporting mercenary
why would he come on your show and I I
said I don't know if I was Eric Prince I
wouldn't have come on my show but I'm
glad he did thank you Eric Prince helped
my career a lot um I don't know why
people come on the show there's a
mixture of reasons I can only speculate
some people like John Bolton they just
enjoy a r Bolton's been debating since y
University they're very Uber confident
in their own abilities and I respect
that it's good let's let's do it I
people you know who want to have a good
argument in good faith um some people
are ignorant they don't do their
homework they don't know anything about
the show when they turn up I did a and
some colleagues of mine from alaz
English here tonight I did an interview
with a senior government official from a
country I won't name who came on a show
I did and as they sat in I could see
them that was a remote interview and I
heard them say to an aid what is this
show who's this host I was like you
really should have asked that days ago
before you turned up to do the injury
and surprise surprise that government
then complained to aleser and the kater
government afterward so ignorant
arrogant some people are just on a book
tour so they sit down for any interviews
um it's become harder as I've become uh
slightly more wellknown in the US being
alges English gave me a certain
anonymity uh in an American audience at
least um but yes it's become much more
difficult it's also become more
difficult Johnny because the people I
really want to interview some of these
kind of right-wing crazies are so crazy
I don't actually want to give put them
on my show there's a chapter that's not
in the book which is when do you not
have an argument when do you walk away
from an argument and I you know I'll
interview John Bolton as repulsive as I
find his politics because I I know that
he believes what he's saying I don't
think he pretends to support the Iraq
War he genuinely believes that was he
thinks it was the right thing to do he
doesn't think he did anything wrong and
he's clearly an intelligent person even
if I don't like him but would I have
like a marjerie Taylor green on my show
no because I just election deniers no
climate change deniers no Holocaust
deniers no I'm not going to argue
reality I'm not going to argue Up Is
Down black is white hot is cold that
stuff I won't do but people who are
willing to come on in good faith even if
they haven't done their homework about
me yeah bring it but as you said more
and more people are doing their homework
and people will you know the show has a
reputation and I'm wondering if if in a
way firstly they're going to shy away
from coming on your show but also
whether that one of the sadnesses of the
current polarized state of particularly
American life but I think it maybe exist
in other places is that the kind of old
school debate that you body and that you
relish is happening more and more rarely
so that actually people are in their
silos speaking only to their political
family um and very rarely are they
colliding with the opposite camp and in
a way well it's you know it's been great
for you but you know you're part of that
because you're on MSNBC most of the
guests on MSNBC are not John Bolton yeah
they're actually Democrats interviewing
other Democrats liberals interviewing
other liberals it's all very cozy and
your show stands out something of an
exception but do you think it is a sort
of endangered form and that the network
you work for is part of the problem so
it's definitely an endangered form and I
but I don't think the part on the
network I'm not saying it because I'm
employed and they pay my bills but
genuinely I I I kind of I kind of get I
get frustrated with this msnbc's liberal
Fox's conservative Cable's divided
America America is divided for many many
reasons well beyond cable news it's a
symptom not a cause yeah it's a symptom
but also
I don't hide the fact that I do an
opinion show and I'm on a network that's
considered liberal left that's very
different to Fox Fox is not a News
Network FOX is a propaganda organ and
you don't have to take my word for it
just check out the leaked emails and
depositions from the fox Dominion case
that's going on right now where Rupert
modok admits under oath that his hosts
were lying and they endorsed a big lion
maybe they shouldn't have where you know
Fox hosts are texting each other saying
well Trump's lawyers are crazy and this
stuff is mad and our viewers they
believe this stuff you know I tell
people you can loathe everything I say
on my show but I guarantee you I say the
same thing in private I don't say
something different to my audience and
then me and Rachel M and Chris Hayes
don't text each other saying ha we
actually love Donald Trump or Joe Biden
actually lost the election it doesn't
happen so on a fundamental factual basis
Fox is not news msnbc's news look I
would like to have more people from I
hate soggy consensus I would like to
have more people to disagree with but
again as I say if part of the political
Spectrum has been taken over by grifters
conmen gas sliders people who don't
believe in stuff then I don't know where
to go to find good faith argument I try
we look for it but it's getting it is
getting harder and harder and it's
depressing one of the reasons I wrote
the book is to try and push back against
that to say these people are degrading
our public discourse our Public Square
there is a way to do it better history
teaches us that my own career teaches us
that Common Sense teaches us that so it
is a kind of Call to Arms in a
sense